we will defend his right to be returned
online as long as he wants to be but the
fact of the matter is he needs to know
what he's talking about no one wants to
stay in France mate no France
look I think the the thing they're all
reacting to is Sarah Braverman called it
an invasion which I think is an
ill-advising to say although if 50 000
people nearly a year are coming in
without any checks yeah on small boats
I mean I wouldn't use the term Invasion
no but you're I mean that's a big
[__] problem that he's dealing with
of course it's a big problem it's a huge
problem and the problem is they're not
being allowed to discuss this problem
honestly because then people come on
from the other side and they hurl
epithets and they say this is racist
this is a sign of the German in the
1930s which is an infantile response
it's an infantile response because if
you know anything about the you know the
Weimar Republic and then how it's slid
into Nazism that is not how what
happened well people weren't trying this
is this is the problem that all these
woke lefties don't seem to have ever
considered in the head if Britain is
such a terrible country hates immigrants
xenophobic racist Etc yeah why are all
these people wanting to come here it's
true and we all know why and you alluded
to your in your brilliant clip at the
beginning right imagine your car breaks
down yeah or catches fire right and
someone goes you know what you can get a
replacement yeah you can either get a
Rolls Royce or a Citron yeah exactly no
one wants to stay in France mate no
France is a [__] even the French
don't want to stand up that's what
they're so upset about brexit oh I want
to go back to England whether you have
money you have to know what you're
talking about yeah when you're saying
something as as inflammatory as in
Century as comparing the current Home
Secretary to Nazi leaders in Germany in
the 30s yeah you better be pretty damn
sure that you're making an accurate
comparison like I you know my position
on on Putin and his invasion of Ukraine
I thought you're going to say my
position on Nazis I'm like no mates I
mean I can elaborate if you want right
yeah but I I cringe a little bit when
people compare Putin to Hitler yeah most
of the time there are some comparisons
to be made but nothing to do with like
racism or ethnic cleansing or anything
like that right
I cruise because it's historically
inaccurate yeah right there's a and and
that
you know that is obviously a much closer
analogy than swella braveman who's just
trying to get to grips with the fact
that we don't have an enforced border at
the moment yeah there's nothing there is
literally nothing to be compared with in
what she said and the third right there
just isn't no and for someone with
millions of followers to be saying that
he's allowed to say it we will defend
his right to be [__] online as long
as he wants to be but the fact of the
matter is he needs to know what the [__]
he's talking about yeah and he doesn't
exactly and this is also the problem as
well you get people who've got huge
online followings they've got massive
careers in which they would incredibly
successful in that career and for Gary
lineker who's been very successful in
two careers number one he was an
outstanding footballer and number two
he's a brilliant broadcaster sports
broadcaster and as a result of that well
let's translate that into human language
for instance yeah he was very good at
hitting a ball with his head and his
feet yeah and then he was very good at
talking to other people who hit balls
with their heads and their feet yeah
that's what he's good at yeah right that
that isn't necessarily the best setup
for commenting on geopolitics no I know
I know and the result of that is because
he's got this huge amount of confidence
because he has been highly successful in
two very competitive Fields he now
thinks that he can then just wade into
every subject without knowing the first
thing about that subject and guess what
Gary yeah car yeah
exactly you can't now listen to me talk
about geopolitics what I don't
understand is why anyone would be
against stopping illegal immigration
because if you care about refugees then
you should care most of all about us
setting up a system where people who are
genuine refugees and and who have a
legitimate Asylum claim can have the
application processed quickly and fairly
yeah instead of having to cross the
channel in a dinghy yeah and compete for
Refugee status with a lot of load of
people who are coming from places like
Albania who are not refugees at all
exactly right uh and and the problem not
the biggest problem actually with what
geralynica is doing and people like him
and what they're saying is that they
will end up we will end up as a result
of what they're saying in a position
where the majority of the public gets so
fed up with having tens of thousands of
people coming to this country illegally
that they will say well I don't want
anyone coming in right and then we're
not going to be in a position to
actually do the what in my opinion is
the right thing which is you know when
when people from Hong Kong were fleeing
Chinese oppression yeah a lot of them
were able to come to this country and
they're exactly the people that we
should be welcoming yeah exactly and we
should welcome English then we've got
this similar culture part formerly part
of the British Empire great food yeah
better than Albanian food so we should
prioritize it prioritize them yeah same
with ukrainians we have some of them
coming in at a time when they genuinely
need it I hope a lot of them will go
back once their country's uh back up and
running uh but we're not going to be in
a position to look after people who
actually need looking after if we allow
loads of people to come in without even
knowing who they are right because you
undermine the published confidence and
the immigration system when I came into
this country in 1995 late 95 early 96.
do you know what the net immigration was
in 1996
we have nearly as many people coming
into Britain illegally yeah as we had
people coming into Britain legally when
I first came here yeah does that is that
not incredible yeah it is we have nearly
the same number of people but they're
coming in illegally and in addition to
that we have hundreds and hundreds of
thousand people coming legally so the
fact that British people are concerned
about it to me is perfectly legitimate
uh whether you agree with it or Not by
the way the problem is people keep
voting uh and not getting the results
that they voted for well this is a
problem it's what happens to a political
system where people consistently vote
for policies that are not getting
implemented eventually people will stop
won't stop voting apathy